hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
utilization of
optical genome mapping in detection and
characterization
of rare genetic markers and pediatric
leukemias
i'm alexis corrales of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by bionano genomics
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit them
at bionanogenomics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit
any technical issues here as well for
example
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
gordana raka
director cytogenomics laboratory
department of pathology and laboratory
medicine
at children's hospital los angeles and
associate professor of clinical
pathology
at keck school of medicine at usc dr
raka
you may now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you very much alexis i would first
like to thank
lab roots and bionano for the
opportunity to share our experience with
optical genome mapping
and i also want to thank all the
attendees who decided to join us today
for this presentation
so i will be telling you today about our
experience with using optical genome
mapping
to detect and characterize rare genetic
markers in pediatric leukemias
this is the outline for today's talk i
will start by briefly describing
principle of optical genome mapping
and then i will discuss two studies one
was focusing on detection of rare
genetic drivers in pediatric leukemias
and in the other study we used
advantages of optical genome mapping for
characterization
of one unusual structural abnormality in
b lymphoblastic leukemia
and known as pex5 intergenic tandem
amplification
or tendon multiplication
so what is the principle of optical
genome mapping this slide is showing
the workflow and principle of this
technology and
starting from the top left corner you
first
isolate high molecular weight dna from
fresh sample
and the first step is to label dna at
short sequences
using fluorescent label fluorescent
markers
and then the molecules are loaded on the
instrument
which will um uh unbind and linearize
those dna molecules
and so that labeling pattern can be
visualized and
imaged and in the next step you can
use the mapping mapping patterns to
assemble contigs and and then
patterns can be compared between your
sample of interest
and reference and that allows you to
detect all the places in the genome that
you are testing
and where labeling pattern differs from
the reference and those changes are
typically due to
different types of structural variants
and either copy number changes or
balance rearrangements
so with this approach um you can detect
variety of structural variants
in your genome of interest and as
compared to the reference
so on the next slide we see different
types of structural variation that can
be
characterized and detected by optical
genome mapping
on the left you see how optical genome
mapping allows to detect copy number
changes
and by comparing your samples in green
and the reference and you can see
um deletions m and duplications
and you can also detect balanced
rearrangements translocations and
inversions for example
and then in the middle you see how
optical genome mapping can be
used to characterize repetitive
sequences which is very difficult to do
by other molecular technologies and so
you see examples
and on this slide of using optical
genome mapping to characterize um
repeat array expansions or tandem
duplications
and and finally um by combining
information from
uh optical um from mapping patterns
and with information of coverage
and and number of molecules coming from
different regions of the genome and you
can get very nice genome-wide
and copy number profile and assessment
and similar to what you would get
from chromosomal microarrays and so in
summary you can detect both balanced and
unbalanced rearrangements and like you
can from karyotype analysis but which
with higher precision and resolution and
you can get copy number profiles
similarly to what you can get from
chromosomal microarrays
so now we would like to move on
and describe our use of optical genome
mapping
in detection of rare genetic drivers in
pediatric leukemias
which were missed by using our routine
genetic testing
methodologies
but before i describe our study i want
to give you some context and
explain why we focused on acute look and
testing and studying acute leukemias
uh acute leukemias are common tumor type
in children
accounting for more than 25 of all
cancer
diagnosis in individuals younger than 20
years of age
and they still remain a important
medical problem because they are still
the second leading cause of cancer death
in children
in spite of all the advances and in
treatment
over the years and importantly genetic
abnormalities have
very um a significant role in risk
ratification
and changing right and choosing right
treatment for patients with acute
leukemias
but we are reaching the point where our
traditional methods of testing karyotype
and fish
are not efficient in detecting all
genetic subtypes that are clinically
significant in this disease
so just to briefly explain why is
karyotype and fish and not sufficient
anymore for our clinical workup of acute
leukemias and children
and if we take example of bll about 15
and 20 years ago we only knew a handful
of cytogenetic subtypes and maybe about
10 different cytogenetic subtypes that
could be picked up
and characterized by chromosome analysis
and in more than 25
of the cases um the underlying genetic
driver
remained unknown simply because
karyotype could not pick up those
abnormalities
but with um availability of advanced
genomic technologies like genome
sequencing
exome sequencing expression and
clustering
um rna-seq we now recognize almost 30
different genetic subtypes of bll
and many of these new genetic subtypes
are already clinically
significant we know they're prognostic
and therapeutic associations
but those are exactly the ones that
historically we were not able to pick up
by karyotype
and uh the the that represented that 25
we were not able to characterize and so
nowadays
we actually can detect um the genetics
um
drivers in almost 95 percent of all the
bll cases
but those novel genetic subtypes need
other genetic testing methodologies to
be
efficiently um identified
in terms of testing challenges in
pediatric acute myeloid leukemia
recent genomic studies have shown that
the genetic profile
in pediatric cases is completely
different
than in adults and very different types
and frequency of abnormalities than what
you see in an adult
and and since most of the testing um is
focusing on the
on adult cases and the essays that are
easily available um for either fusion
detection
or detection of sequence variants are
tailored towards adult cases and do not
work well
for pediatric aml
in addition in pediatric cases you have
very high heterogeneity of genetic
drivers and they
tend to be fusions um they're
individually very rare
but collectively fusions are the key
drivers
in pediatric aml and they arise from
structural rearrangements uh which are
um
challenging to to detect by existing
methodologies
with high resolution and and also
because of high heterogeneity uh
targeted assays are not working very
well so you need methodologies that will
allow for efficient genome by detection
of structural changes and at the same
time while there are all these
challenges
the number of markers that are having
prognostic significance is constantly
increasing so
we want to be more and more efficient in
detecting them and detecting them
at the time of diagnosis so to address
these new needs
and in genetic testing for pediatric
leukemias
at our laboratory at chla we implemented
multimodal testing that in addition to
routinely using karyotype
and extensive fish panels me also uses
routinely chromosomal microarrays and
our custom next generation sequencing
panel that we call onco kids
which was especially designed for
pediatric cancers including pediatric
hematologic malignancies
however even when we apply all these
testing methodologies
our recent retrospective studies show
that in vll cases we still have 15
percent of cases where
underlying genetic marker remains
unknown
and then in aml we have about five
percent of the cases
uh where with combination of our current
testing methodologies we still cannot
identify the key genetic driver and so
that prompted us to continue looking for
a more comprehensive and novel methods
to do our diagnostic testing
for leukemias and we are in the process
of validating rna-seq for fusion
detection
and we are also validating exome
sequencing for dna sequence variants
however we are constantly looking for
other options for
doing more efficient clinical testing
because the goal is not only to be
comprehensive
but also to be very efficient and and to
have
a good um
good turnaround times um as well as
reasonable cost of our casting
so that got us interested into optical
genome mapping
and what in particularly sparked our
interest um
were results of this multi-center study
which looked exactly in hematologic
malignancies
and utility of optical genome mapping
and characterizing
and previously detected and number
structural variants
and so in this study man they were able
to show that optical genome mapping
detected copy number abnormalities and
structural variants
that were previously detected by
karyotype and fish
but also detected additional changes
that were missed by traditional methods
in 11
of the cases and it refined structural
variants that were
detected by karyotype but could not be
accurately characterized
in additional 24 of the cases so it
certainly
looked like a very promising technology
especially seemed to work very well in
hematologic malignancies and we wanted
to
test it ourselves and see if it can help
us
in some of our unknown and difficult
cases
so we did a small feasibility study
to determine if optical genome mapping
can detect clinically significant
genetic drivers in pediatric leukemias
which were missed by comprehensive
molecular evaluation in
our laboratory and so we were able to
find
um nine cases which were previously
um tested and remained unknown
for which we had materials saved to do
isolation of high molecular weight dna
and those were eight blll cases and um
so far and unfortunately only one aml
case
and what was striking for us in these
bll cases
is that out of eight cases um six were
classified
based on clinical presentation as high
risk
which showed us that in these cases with
unknown genetics after our comprehensive
evaluation
and we have enrichment for high-risk
cases and i think that that stresses the
importance of and having good methods to
and and more efficient methods and to
tackle these very difficult cases that
remain unknown
and since um those are the high-risk
ones for you from diagnosis one two
um and know as much information and
choose the right approach
so um i will um died immediately
into our results with optical genome
mapping
and when we look at our eight blll cases
in two out of eight cases
optical genome mapping detected a
previously reported
and known um driver fusions
which remained unknown after our
comprehensive analysis
so i will describe these cases in detail
and this was the first case
it was initially diagnosed as standard
risk bll
but unexpectedly it had poor response to
treatment so the patient had residual
disease
at the end of induction had to be
further treated more aggressively
and our genetic testing started by
karyotype which did detect
two rearrangements there seemed to be
translocation between chromosomes two
and five and as well as inversion on
chromosome 14
but at the time of initial diagnosis we
really did not understand the
significance of these rearrangements
by chromosomal macroarray testing we did
see a deletion of icarus gene
which is known as poor prognostic marker
in bll so that did make us concerned
about this case that it might not be
just a simple standard risk bll
but we didn't really know more
specifically what were important genetic
drivers
in this case so when we
got optical genome mapping results back
it
confirmed the presence of the same
abnormalities that we saw by karyotype
we were reassured and that it also
showed presence of translocation 2
5 and in version 14 and shown on the
left in the circus plot
but um more interestingly and
importantly there were very
important genes at the break point for
this translocation to
5. on chromosome 2 it was spt-bn1 gene
and then on chromosome 5 pdgfr beta gene
and we got excited because fusions that
involve ptgf are beta gene
are known to be associated with a high
risk subtype of bll known as
philadelphia-like or ph like vlo blo
and also even more significantly and
they seem to
um indicate response um of
leukemia to tyson kinase inhibitors
and so you can target um cases that pgfr
beta fusion with existing tyrosine
kinase inhibitors
so we obviously wanted to confirm that
the fusion was real
and we have fish probe it is for pdgfr
beta and which
clearly showed that there was pdgfr beta
rearrangement
and since we are validating rnac for
fusion detection
we were able to run the sample by
rna-seq and that also confirmed the
presence of the fusion
and so what is the significance of this
binding as i mentioned
it's a fusion associated page like bll
which is high risk so there is
um prognostic significance there is
treatment significance because these
fusions um
respond to targeting by tyrosine kinase
inhibitors
and then for us the important question
was why did we miss that at initial
diagnosis
and and we didn't think when we saw
karyotype findings about this particular
fusion because a
fusion with this this particular partner
spt
bn1 has not been seen in bll before
it has been described only in few cases
of another hematologic malignancy
myoproliferation neoplasm with
azinophilia and pdgfr beta
rearrangements
and this is adult disease that we didn't
expect to
so we did not expect this fusion in
pediatric bll
and and and that also explains why
distribution was not part of our design
for our oncogets ngs panel
and we also did not expect ph like bll
subtype in
patients who presented clinically as
standard risk although there are some
rare cases of standardized patients
who end up being ph like bll positive
but in with optical genome mapping we
were able to pick up this abnormality
and as i mentioned
there are some both prognostic and
treatment implications
the second case where optical genome
mapping detected previously known
previously published and
described fusion in bll and there was a
patient who also was diagnosed initially
as standard risk
but he had even worse response to
treatment his uh
disease was refractory and he had to be
enrolled in carti trial to get him into
remission
however he relapsed very quickly after
a completion of a treatment and and was
referred to chla for another
um clinical trial with car t cells and
we repeated his genetic testing when he
was referred to chla
and karyotype came back as completely
normal now cma also did not find any
significant
copy number abnormalities and then
oncogenes only
found ndress and the hotspot mutation
and some variants of unknown
significance but nothing that would
and tell us what is the key genetic
driver for this leukemia
so to our surprise optical genome
mapping
detected a variety of structural
variants that and we were completely
unaware of and the karyotype was normal
and so that showed us that and we
probably did not get leukemia cells to
grow in culture
and because this patient leukemia
actually had a very complex genome
and among all these structural variants
detected by optical genome mapping
one really stood out which was a
three-way rearrangement
and involving chromosomes 1 12
and six so um try to highlight it in the
circus plot on the left
but at the break point and chromosomes
one
and and twelve were some important genes
on chromosome one it was mass 2d and
then on 12 swell
fox j2
so why is this important meth2d
fusions with different partners are
known to define
a specific genetic subtype of bll
and then fox j2 uh it has been described
as one of the partners of math2d
but it's a very rare partner only seen
in maybe one case um in one
cohort study and again explaining why
this was not a part of the design for
our oncologist panel
and why we missed it by our
comprehensive initial testing
and we ran this sample on rna-seq and
the diffusion got confirmed
and we verified that it was real but the
clinical significance of this
is that method diffusions are known to
be associated with very high risk
disease
and so if this was known in diagnosis it
would certainly it certainly helped to
risk stratified this patient
appropriately and retrospectively it
really
well explains his very aggressive
clinical course and poor response to
treatment
so moving on in in the
addition to known previously reported
fusions in
two out of our eight cases um optical
genome mapping detected
novel candidate fusions and that have
not been
described previously but it may
represent novel discovery
so one of these cases it was a high-risk
pll
where um your previous testing um
detected some
non-specific copy number changes by
array and
but there was nothing that now really um
classifies as known genetic driver in in
vll
and so optical genome mapping in this
case um
suggested the presence of a
rearrangement between chromosomes six
and x with two very interesting genes at
the break points
an atrx on x m and bach
2 um on chromosome 6. and so based on
optical genome mapping
and it was expected that there will be
bsh2 atrx fusion present in this sample
and and we ran the sample as well on
rna-seq
and then confirmed that the diffusion is
real however this fusion has not been
described previously in bll it may
potentially
represent new discovery and we're
excited about it
and think of it as a very good candidate
because both parts of genes have been
previously implicated in bll
atrx is an encodes epigenetic regulator
and has been shown to be mutated in
relapse cases of bll
and then bach2 is a transcription
regulator
that has important role in regulating t
cell function and b cell maturation and
so based on their known
functions both these genes and are
expected to be important in bll
that they may be important in bll
pathogenesis and so we are
um now working on further further
proving the functional significance
of this fusion and then the second case
of where optical genome mapping
detected novel candid fusion it was
another high-risk
patient with very aggressive clinical
course who was referred um
to chla after a relapse for car t
therapy
and in this case um optical genome
mapping
detected multiple structural variants
that were
missed by karyotyping including
inversion on chromosome 9
with st rbp gene and jack 2 gene
at the breakpoints and so optical genome
mapping results suggested the presence
of scrbp jack to fusion and we were
excited about this result because jack 2
fusions are known to be associated ph
like bll
again sdrbp has not been described
previously
as one of the partners and and for this
fusion we still don't have rnac
confirmation
but it's another very promising
candidate for a novel fusion
so to quickly summarize our experience
with bll cases
previously reported clinically
significant fusions were detected in two
out of eight cases
and novel candidate fusions were
detected in two out of eight cases
and then i didn't really specifically
show this in detail
but in almost all the cases seven out of
eight
and then optical genome mapping detected
structural variants
and that were missed by previous um
karyotype analysis
and and that we were unaware of based on
other testing that we did
in the lab there was only one case where
optical genome mapping did not detect
the structural variants that
um enable structural variants and that
we were not aware of
so as i mentioned so far we were only
able to test one aml case
and but uh the results were very
interesting so i really wanted to share
this case with you
uh this was infant aml case so
so the this is a baby girl who presented
aml soon after birth and she was
diagnosed with
aml with minimal differentiation or
m0 subtype is an fab1 classification
which is a very rare subtype morphologic
subtype
of the disease and it's very little
known about genetic basis of this
particular subtype
our initial karyotype analysis uh showed
what looked to us like possible
translocation between chromosomes 6 and
20.
but the bending pattern didn't quite fit
so we indicated with the question mark
that we were not absolutely sure
about the nature of this rearrangement
and the other unusual thing was that
this was present in all the cells and so
we were not even sure whether this might
be
a constitutional balanced rearrangement
in this patient completely unrelated to
her leukemia
and all the other genetic testing that
we did including fish and cma
and oncogenes panel testing um was
essentially negative
so when we got optical genome mapping
results back for this case to our
surprise
and there was evidence of rearrangement
that was three-way that was more complex
than we
anticipated based on karyotype and so it
was rearrangement that did include
chromosomes 6 and 20
and but it also include pr of the x
chromosome
and on the right is um
there are more detailed results of
optical genome mapping um
showing the scheme of what was the
nature of this rearrangement
and based on optical genome mapping
results and
so and there was translocation of xp
material
to chromosome 20 to the q arm and then
chromosome 20 material was translocated
to
chromosome 6 the q arm and then material
from chromosome 6
was translocated back to x chromosome to
the pr
but in addition to translocation there
was also a small inversion
and in the longever of chromosome 6.
so there was first inversion of a
segment of 6q
and then it got translocated to the xp
and so of course we were very curious um
to see if we can verify this a
rearrangement and by looking back at the
karyotype
and now when we knew exactly what to
look for
we were actually able to appreciate that
and chromosome x was also abnormal
and then if you look at this um a
partial stereotype
on the right side of the slide and
you can see that one of the x
chromosomes has a abnormal
looking p arm because that's six q
material translocated there
and xp material is on the long arm of
chromosome 20
and then a 20q material is at the long
arm of chromosome 6.
and so and now we understand why the
bending pattern didn't quite fit for us
initially
and but we were not able without knowing
what to look for
to actually accurately characterize this
rearrangement
and so i think that this illustrates um
one of the strengths of optical genome
mapping that was also
um described in that multi-center study
that it allows you to more accurately
characterize abnormalities that you see
by karyotype
what was also exciting to us for this
case
was that at the breakpoints of
chromosome 6
and x there were some very interesting
genes on chromosome 6 it was
meb and and known oncogene
and and genes which is important in
hemoplatic tissues
and then on x chromosome yet one a very
important transcription factor
in hematopoietic tissues and so
ogm results suggested the presence of
maybe get a one fusion
but if you look at the bottom how these
genes are oriented on their
corresponding chromosomes
and if you just have a simple
translocation between chromosome
6 and x and you would end up in having
these two genes in opposite orientations
and that would not result in the
productive fusion
and so that explains why there was
inversion of a segment of 6q
before the material was translocated to
the x chromosome because
um only that inversion allowed
to create productive fusion between meib
and gatta 1. and so and now
everything is um starting to come
together and and to make sense if we
assume that
the this rearrangement indeed results in
gato1 fusion
and so we were excited to come to try to
confirm this by rna-seq and
rna-seq data it very clearly confirmed
the presence of the fusion
and it also showed the splice variants
that
corresponded to what was previously
reported for this particular fusion
and so the mem exons six seven
and and eight were involved with um exon
five of gada one and that's what has
been described previously for this
fusion
and so on the right in the middle you
see the scheme from
one of the papers that describes this
fusion in another um
aml case and they also show a fusion
between
mib exon 8 and and gana one exon
um five and as i described previously
the fusion made perfect sense and
because
both genes have very important roles in
hematopoietic
tissues and amid is known to be very
highly expressed and in early stages in
um and undifferentiated cells and then
its expression
goes down during differentiation and if
you add a one it's
opposite me it
promotes differentiation so its
expression goes
up during differentiation process and
and interestingly these two genes
are co-regulating each other there are
um
binding sites for gata one in
mid-regulatory regions
so as data one goes up it binds to mid
regulatory regions and participates to
down regulation of mib and so the
hypothesis for this fusion was that
when the fusion disrupts gata1 then then
and there is
um no um binding of data one to mib
regulator regions there is no midtown
regulation and that results
in very high expression not only of the
fusion but also
non-translocated um normal mib allele
um and that interferes with
differentiation and drives glucogenesis
and so the fusion is um has been
described previously and has some very
interesting
biology however and what was known about
this fusion was
um very different from what our case
suggests and
so we think that that our case will
um provide some novel insights into
biology of this particular fusion
and the fusion is exceedingly rare it
has been
reported only in a handful of cases and
the biggest
um case cohort to if i can put it that
way
describing this fusion and only had four
cases
and interestingly they were all infant
cases
um and the all patients were male
and so the authors hypothesized and that
this fusion
might be restricted to male patients and
because they only have one x chromosome
and one copy of gato1
and there is no normal copy uh to
compensate
when you have gata1 participating in the
fusion
and that drives leukemogenesis and the
other interesting
finding in this paper was that all the
patients had
acute basophilic leukemia which is a
very rare subtype morphologic subtype
and but it different from what we saw in
our patient
so in contrast to this study our patient
was a female
and our patient did not have acute
basophilic leukemia
she had a leukemia with minimal
differentiation
and and finally um
we do not really think that explanation
why this would be restricted to male
patients really holds because although
male patients have one x chromosome
and in one copy of the other one females
also have one
active copy of data one and since
the second x chromosome is inactive and
so there is biologically really no
reason why this would be restricted to
male patients
although one can maybe hypothesize that
there could be some
compensatory reactivation of and get a
one
and from inactive x chromosome in
females
and so we really think that this is not
going to be restricted just to male
patients
and and that this might be under
recognized abnormality
and because when you
only study these cases by karyotype and
since the the genes are in opposite
orientation simple translocation
is not going to result in productive
fusion so all these cases will have
more complex rearrangements and there
will be no consistency from case to case
and that prevents from
recognizing this as a recurrent
abnormality and and recognizing this
um as a more common type
or abnormality in leukemia and than what
we think
yeah so i think that this is a very
interesting case that
shows how the optical genome mapping
help helped us
not only to find diagnosis for one our
patient but
to get some very interesting insights
and into a rare
um genetic abnormality in aml and then
from clinical perspective um
all previously published um patients did
really well
and and they responded very well to
therapy they were in remission
at a time of uh publication um
and so so did our patient he responded
very well
and and so we think that this infusion
will be
um recognized as being associated with
a good prognosis so now moving on me
what were the other insights about
optical genome mapping from our pilot
study
and since we had chromosomal microarrays
results for all our cases
um and we were able to compare copy
number profiles from chromosomal
microarrays
and at the bottom and from optical
genome mapping
on the top and you can probably
appreciate that they're very
comparable um so optical genome mapping
allows you to get genome by topic number
assessment
and that's very comparable to what you
would get from
a chromosomal microarrays
as i mentioned earlier in almost all our
cases
um optical genome mapping um showed
structural variants
and that we did not um pick up by
karyotype analysis
and so cytogenetics more commonly than
we realize
misses structural variants simply
because those abnormal clones don't grow
in culture
and and so i think this illustrates
advantage of optical genome mapping that
it does
not require and growing cells in culture
because of that as we
we've seen from our small pilot study
often leads to
false negative results and finally
er what was very um important to me
as a cytogeneticist was that optical
genome mapping gives you
um information about chromosomal
mechanism about the nature of
chromosomal rearrangement that results
in an abnormal fusion
when you detect abnormal fusions by
methods like rna-seq
you can see the presence of a fusion but
you really don't know
what is the chromosomal rearrangement
that resulted in the fusion
and and with optical genome mapping you
do get that information we were able
to and find fusions that resulted from
complex three-way rearrangements and
from inversions
and and i think that that is also
important um
in understanding mechanisms in
understanding bases
and pathogenesis and of these important
mutations in leukemia
so um to summarize the first study
in first part of the talk um in our
unknown cases optical
genome mapping detected known clinically
significant fusions and but also some
novel candidate fusions illustrating
more clinical
clinical and research potential of this
technology
and it showed very nice concordance with
chromosomal macro race and detection of
copy number
abnormalities genome-wide and detected
presence of structural variants
in all the cases with normal karyotype
and in almost all the cases that we
included in our study
and finally it allows to decipher
chromosomal mechanism that
and generate and generate oncogenic
drivers
um in contrast to rna-c confusion
detection from rna
so now we'd like to move on and and
describe how we use
optical genome mapping um to
characterize um
rare abnormality in bll that i refer to
as intergenic tandem multiplication
in fact pak5
so in this second study we tried to
utilize
another advantage or a strength of
optical genome mapping which is its
ability to characterize repetitive
sequences
as you know um the characterizing repeat
is very difficult by molecular methods
and a karyotype is who has too low
resolution
for many types of repeats in the genome
and
chromosomal macroarrays usually don't
even have
any probes for repetitive regions and
and shortly sequencing
also doesn't work very well because um
reads from repetitive
regions cannot be mapped back to the
genome but optical genome mapping
and provides the advantage that you can
directly visualize
and in these repetitive regions and long
dna molecules
and and you can um really efficiently
um detect and study repeat and one well
in well-known example
are repeats associated with um rare
genetic disorders fascia's capital of
humor or muscular dystrophy and so in
this disease um
disease is caused by a
decrease in the number of repeats and in
the region of chromosome 4 by repeat
contraction
and it's a very difficult region to
study um
so um before optical genome mapping the
only way to detect this abnormality and
make a diagnosis with southern blood
but optical genome mapping allows to
very um
clearly visualize these contractions of
repeat arrays
and so that now there are already
clinical laboratories that have
validated testing for this disorder
and using optical genome mapping and so
in our
next study we use this ability of
optical genome mapping to characterize
repetitive regions
and to get insight into this
rare abnormality in bll that we got
interested in
so the way we got interested in this
abnormality
was starting from a specific case and we
had a case of bll standard
risk where after all our testing we
really could not tell what was the main
genetic driver
however we really scrutinized the data
wanting to know what was the key finding
in this leukemia
and and we saw a very small um copy
number gain
that overlapped with the part of the pax
5 gene
and peptide abnormalities are pretty
common in bll so we first did not think
much
much of it and but and since there were
no other other
um genomic drivers um in in this
particular case
and we decided to look a little uh
in more detail and so the duplications
seem to involve pi
prime end of the gene exons from one to
five
and then um to are surprised it actually
turned out
that this was at the time known
recurrent
abnormality in bll at the time it was
described and studied by two european
groups and who studied it by mlpa
and what they found was that this occurs
in about one to three percent
of bll cases that it typically involves
exons two to five
within max of x5 and so um
very similar to what we saw in our first
case and by fish they verified that this
was uh
within pax five that extra copies were
within the gene that they are not
inserted somewhere else in the genome
and then what was particularly
interesting is that and this did not
um occur in any cases that had
other major subtype defining genetic
drivers
and so it seemed mutually exclusive with
other major drivers and they made
hypothesis that this abnormality
probably this defines a new genetic
subgroup
of bll a very interesting exception was
petra eight sierra r8 crlf2 fusion which
was seen in subset of these cases
however this fusion is tricky because it
can be primary driver
in zero to positive ph like blo but it
can also be secondary abnormality
in variety of different subtypes and so
authors hypothesize that this could
still be
a secondary abnormality with pax by
copy number gain being um the primary
and they refer to this abnormality as
pex5 intergenic
amplification and but and i think that
the number of extra copies does not
quite reach the definition of
amplification
so i mentioned it as
intergenic multiplication
so then um the further insight into this
abnormality came from studies um in 2019
that defined a completely new subtype of
ell that was
driven exactly by fax 5 abnormalities so
they refer
to the subtype as text 5 alt and they
show evidence that pack 5 changes are
primary drivers in this subtype
although they are commonly also seen as
secondary in other subtypes
and interestingly they had a significant
number of cases in the
pax 5 alt cohort where they saw the same
intergenic multiplication and that
that we saw in our initial case and so
and another this uh suggests that that
the abnormality is indeed
associated uh with um its um own subtype
um and that it probably is one of the
abnormalities that
and define the specified alt and bll
so um we continue to be very interested
with
i thought that there are still many
unanswered questions about this
abnormality
and so we decided to determine its
prevalence its exact structure
and associated genetic changes in our
cohort are
of bll and because we took advantage of
the fact that we routinely do
chromosomal macroarray studies
so it was very easy to us to go back and
retrospectively analyze all our cases
and then see how often are we detecting
this abnormality
and so in a cohort of more than 200
cases we had
five cases of this textvive abnormality
for the
prevalence about 2 percent and then
based on the ray data
it seemed to have pretty consistent size
about 25 kb
uh with only the first case that i
described and being a little
larger and it always seemed to
involve axons two to five as previously
described
and then um by a chromosomal microarray
it was obvious that there was more than
one extra copy
there was based on cma it seems that
there are a total of four copies
but you know we were also aware that um
maybe cma does not
exactly um accurately determine the
number of copies
so it was very intriguing to us that you
almost
that you never seem to have just one
extra copy there always seems to be more
than one extra
and so we really wanted um to verify
what is the number of copies what is
exactly the structure
and of this abnormality and um
what is the orientation of these um
extra copies
of the duplication and we thought that
optical genome mapping could be
exactly the right tool um to answer our
questions
and because we expected that in long and
labeled molecules that you use in
optical genome mapping you will be
able to directly visualize and these
extra copies and and
and see exactly the number and the
structure
so we were able to um find residual
material
in two out of the five cases that were
positive
by cma and these are optical genome
mapping results for the first of those
two cases
and to our surprise um there there seem
to be
four extra copies uh for the total of
five
me which is higher than uh what was
suggested based on cma
and but we were very confident that this
is the
correct result because optical genome
mapping allows to also measure the size
of this
insertion if we can call it that way and
then the size was also consistent with
having four extra copies for the total
of five
and then in the second case there we
actually had
five extra copies for the total of six
copies
again much higher number than what we
thought based on cma results
and but this was also verified based on
the size of the insertion
and so this showed us that copy number
was
um underestimated by cma and that
really to get full information about the
range
of how many extra copies you have in
this abnormality it would be important
to
study additional cases by optical genome
mapping
and the other insight that we got from
our studies about this abnormality it
was about its structure
so in our cases also involved typically
exons two to five
and when you look at the junction
between these axons and
it is predicted at mrna level that it
would be in frame
so this abnormality is not really
predicted to disrupt the gene
but rather to result in extra copies
of a certain region of the protein and
and these axons
exactly code for dna binding paired
domain of x5
and so you would expect to get a protein
that has extra copies of the dna binding
pair domain
and that obviously um is expected to
um to change downstream regulation of
tax by target genes because this is a
transcription factor
very important for b cell and
differentiation
and what was also very interesting to us
is that in our cases we also did not
have any of key genetic drivers
and all cases were negative for um other
genetic drivers that define
subtype of bll so our results are also
consistent with this being the primary
and subtype defining driver
um likely associated with the specs five
alt subtype of bll
but we did have two cases with p2r by 8
crlf2 fusion as described previously so
again we are recapitulating this
uh previously described association of
this abnormality
with p2r-802 fusion and we also detected
some other genetic abnormalities that
have previously
described to be enriched in cases with
this pex-5 intergenic tandem
multiplication
so in the conclusions for the second
study we saw text five intergenic tender
multiplication two percent of our cases
and it involved typically exons two to
five and
and based on optical genome mapping we
now know that um
there is multiple extra copies and in
our cases we saw four or five extra
copies in direct orientation
and this is predicted to results in
extra copies of the dna binding region
of pax 5
and it seems to act as primary driver
because it seems mutually exclusive with
other genetic drivers that define
subtypes of vl and
but it shows this very interesting
association and synergism with p2ra hcr
left 2 fusion
and finally we verified that optical
genome mapping is indeed a very good
method
to study structure of this abnormality
and however there are still very
interesting remaining questions where it
comes to this
pac-5 intergenic tandem multiplication
and i think that that it would be
important to determine number of extra
copies in additional changes and to see
what is the range
it seems to be required that there is
more than one extra copy
and for this um to be oncogenic
however we really would need to know um
what exactly is the range um interesting
question is what
is the mechanism of these duplications
are they repeat mediated why they
recurrently occur
um at the same region of the gene and
how they lead to oncogenesis what are
the downstream effects on the pac-5
function
and and downstream pacified targets and
then it will be
important to understand fully its
association possible association with
pakistan all bll is this really
one of the genetic drivers associated
this particular
subtype of the disease and finally
another very intriguing question is to
understand
synergism with p2r802 fusion which seems
to
very frequently be seen in these cases
that have pac-5m
antigenic and the multiplication and so
i really advocate
and that and more more cases with this
of this abnormality
and it should be studied by optical
genome mapping or
a method that allows to correctly
characterize the structure of this
abnormality
so to finalize and as in our overall
conclusion from
the two studies that we were able to
conduct so far using optical genome
mapping
in first study we verified that it can
detect previously undetected known and
novel fusions in pediatric leukemias
and while also detecting abnormalities
that we previously
um and detected by our routine testing
like karyotyping fish and chromosomal
macroarray studies
and then in the second study um and we
demonstrated that optical genome mapping
allowed accurate characterization
of pac-5 intergenic tell the
multiplication
so it has advantage in studying
repetitive regions
so with that uh i would like to thank
all the collaborators um
on the study these studies and
my colleagues and hematology laboratory
um
in as a center for precise medicine um
at chla
and um also members of the banana
genomics team
and who helped generously with
running and analyzing our cases and
interpreting the data and of course i
want to thank
um all of you again for joining us for
this presentation
thank you
thank you dr raka for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many questions as
we have time for
so let's get started dr raka our first
question from the audience is going to
be a two-part question
the first part is based on what factors
did you decide on selecting particular
patients
to test with the ogm on cytogenetically
normal patients
and so our key criteria
was and whether we were able to identify
a main genetic driver and for that case
and so if we did all our testing
and in a karyotype
fish panel chromosomal macroarrays and
and our oncogenes panel testing and we
still could not detect
the key genetic driver and there are
known drivers in
leukemias that define subtypes of the
disease
and so if we couldn't find one of those
um those cases we consider
unknown unclassified in terms of their
genetics
so we really focused on those those are
the ones that are still obviously very
challenging to us
and and then um if we also
knew about the patient uh that had
unusual clinical course
and that disease did not respond what
respond well to treatment that the
patient relapse and then made that made
it even more important
to understand what was genetics um of
that particular leukemia
in essence there are many genetic
abnormalities that are known to be
associated with high risk and aggressive
disease so those are our criteria but
then there was also practical criteria
and whether we really had the material
left and
and to do optical genome mapping um
because these were all
retrospective studies and it was all
based on cases that we tested previously
in the lab
and and sometimes we do have some
residual material left that sometimes
we don't so and that was there was that
practical limitation
wonderful and so the second part to this
audience question is
would you see this technology in a
routine diagnostic lab
along with ngs i think it has
really good potential to be to be used
um
and and to really be advantageous um
in clinical testing um there are some
laboratories that are very
um quickly very actively working on
on validating this work for clinical use
and because in the research setting it
has shown um
advantages in detection detecting
structural variants
it has it has many things that are
attractive when you look at a um
some a test being used in the clinical
setting
and and um
i know that um some labs are
already working on and validating it for
clinical use
and there was recently a very nice
symposium
um organized by nano with and speakers
from all over the world
and sharing their experience with
optical genome mapping and several
laboratories described
moving this towards clinical validation
and because as i mentioned in my talk
and it detects a very well structural
variance both
copy number changes and balance
structural rearrangements and which is
what you can do by karyotype um but
and it detects that with better
precision you know at higher resolution
and so and it it potentially could be
a very good alternative for to karyotype
analysis and fish testing
and specifically we we um
are interested in hematologic
malignancies so in that area
and and um we have
now our own hands-on you know firsthand
of our experience on our own cases
showing
and that it detects um abnormalities
that we missed by other
technologies so musa i certainly see
potential
and i know of laboratories that are um
already validating it for clinical use
great thank you so much so um back to
another two-part question for you dr
raka
when validating fusions using rna-seq
was the sequence mapping done against a
reference genome or
a reference transcriptome and why did
you choose that reference type
um so it was um it was a
mapped against reference transcriptome
and i wish i could give you
a lot of technical details um
but but i don't because um i'm not
bioinformatician by training
we have an uh bioinformatics team at
chla
and that was um helping us to develop
and and
um implement this test and so
mapping is against the transcriptome but
unfortunately i don't
really get um we have a lot of technical
details
that you can share today i'm certainly i
will certainly be happy to
provide those details in in the future
through
email or other methods
great now do you believe um
uh i'm so sorry here's our next question
so
what cma testing platform are you using
our laboratory uses um a
cytoskin hd arrays from term of fisher
previously developed by fmetrix so
that's what we use
whenever we have fresh material
and both for our constitutional cases
and for our oncology cases
when we get fresh material which is most
often the case with leukemias
and and then for some subset of our
solid tumors um but we did validate
um anka scan platform as well um for
ffbe
samples you know we have that valid in
the web as well and use that
when we get fmp
so we do have time for a couple more
questions but i do want to remind our
audience
any questions that we aren't able to get
to and those that come in during the on
demand period
will be addressed by dr rocco via the uh
email address that you provided at
registration
so dr raka do you think that there is a
gender bias
for example male predominance for
leukemia
driven by the mib gata one fusion and
if yes what is the possible mechanism
yeah thank you for that question i
really thought that that case with
me gotta one fusion was quite
fascinating
um and and i since all
other previous cases were indeed a male
um that might indicate that there could
be potentially gender bias
and interestingly it has been described
for other genes that
map on x chromosome and for other um
oncogene and tumor suppressor genes that
map um
an x chromosome and that there seems to
be
uh if when they are key drivers that
they that they are more commonly seen in
male patients
and so although and functionally male
females also have just one active copy
of those genes
and there still seems to be in other
cases as well
um some male predominance when the gene
is is mapped on
x and but what exactly would be the
mechanism is a very i think interesting
uh research question and whether there
is
um some as i mentioned earlier some type
of compensatory
reactivation of the inactive copy in
females and that makes those
um those leukemias those genes
makes it more difficult for these genes
to um to be
fully oncogenic and realize their
oncogenic potential
and so i think that and that that is is
very very interesting uh research
question um that
we we might look into or i i'm hoping
that some other groups
uh will be interested in but to answer
the question
directly i think that there might be
some male bias um based on
on the fact that other reported cases
were all in male patients
wonderful so it looks like we have time
for
one more question so talk to raka first
off thank you for the fantastic webinar
would you like to comment on the impact
of the percentage of
abnormal clone on the utilization of ogm
um yeah that's always a big concern in
cancer testing and we want to be able to
detect abnormalities that are present
at a low level and and i know that there
are studies out there that looked into
sensitivity of optical genome mapping
for
abnormalities present at low level so it
depends a little bit um similar to ngs
depends a little bit on and how um
if i could put it that way depth of
coverage or how many reads
you're going to analyze but i know that
they have shown in previous studies that
um it can go down to five percent
sensitivity so it can detect
abnormalities that are present
as low as five percent and and then if
you really push it
um and and do a very um high coverage
maybe even lower than that
wonderful thank you again dr raka for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lavers and
our sponsor bionanogenomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us oh
excuse me i've re-said that um and
they're interesting questions uh
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us stay healthy
stay safe and until next time bye-bye
everyone